there is relief this morning but also
concern and confusion over california
governor gavin newsom's decision to lift
covet's stay at home orders
hospitalizations and the average number
of cases are going down statewide partly
because of that lockdown
but there's also a threat from new
strains of the virus and that threat is
rising
john the big liotti now reports from los
angeles
after two months 1.8 million cases and
over
17 thousand deaths california's lockdown
is over everything that should be down
is down case rates positivity rates
hospitalizations icus
but the governor said the state's next
hurdle will be in vaccinating
all of the state's 40 million residents
at the current pace
california won't vaccinate even half of
its residents
until thanksgiving more than half of
california's doses are still on the
shelf
as the state prioritizes vaccinating
people like front line workers and
seniors i think we're kind of past this
point of worrying about
how much we have in store and we're
starting to worry more about where's the
supply going to come from
with new variants on the rise the need
to vaccinate is becoming more urgent
southern california is already home to
its own unique variant
cal 20c researchers say it's more
contagious
and it's now responsible for over 40
percent of all infections in the region
sars code 2 is mutating to evade us
right
but we can stop it from becoming
infectious and so the fact that we find
it start to increase over the holidays
is a reflection of our behavior even as
california moves out of the lockdown
the virus has left unimaginable loss in
its wake
it took the life of 33 year old jasmine
jacobo
who left behind five daughters her
brother fidencio
has taken them all in you know it's
tough
you know the sun shines
on us but then we have our cloudy days
too
you know these girls that they're going
through so much
and it's the beginning the love that she
shared with everybody
was amazing she was a beautiful person
their loss is simply unimaginable there
is some encouraging news on the
vaccination front modernist says their
vaccine works
on most mutant trains though they are
creating a booster shot for the more
contagious
south african variant anthony jonathan
thank you